the
carolina panthers this is an nfl team
that i don't follow and i certainly
don't intend to follow now
they've got a cheerleading squad just
like all football teams do so they got
this cheerleading squad frankly it's my
favorite part of football games
not anymore
because the carolina panthers
cheerleading squad
will now feature a man
dressed as a woman
doing all the cheers
the man goes by justine simone lindsey
something tells me that's not his real
name but that's what he goes by now and
uh he announced on instagram that he is
now
uh going to join the panthers top cats
and this was confirmed by the
cheerleading director sean delay lanuet
to buzzfeed
obviously wrong obviously gross
obviously
no normal person wants to see this
so why is it happening
the reason it's happening is not just
because this guy has some sexual
disorders
the reason it's happening is not just
because our society has lost its mind on
this fad
right now this this fashionable ideology
that says that men can secretly be women
which is going to fall out of fashion at
some point but right now it's really
really hot
there's a deeper reason that this is
happening
it's actually even beyond the weird
sexual
confusion and sexual ideologies the
deeper reason this is happening is
because of selfishness because
increasingly the only people that we
ever consider in our entire public life
is ourselves me me
me me
the question you've got to ask yourself
when
in a sane society insane football team
in the same cheerleading squad
when someone applies to be a cheerleader
the first question you got to ask
yourself is
how will this help
the cheerleading squad
not how will this help the individual
who's applying it's not about them it's
about the team
at first it's about the squad and then
when you're talking about cheerleading
it's not even just about the
cheerleading team it's about the
football team the question you gotta ask
yourself is
what is cheerleading for
what's it for is cheerleading for
making sexually confused men feel
temporarily better about themselves
maybe if it even does that or is
cheerleading for
cheering on the team
cheering on the football team in this
case
what is it for this actually really
began even before the gender ideology
took off
because
in the way olden days you had
cheerleaders and the cheerleaders would
show up to the football games and throw
the pom-poms in the air and say
go team
then
sometime within the last few decades
cheerleading became its own sport so you
would have a friend of mine would do
this cheerleader friends of mine would
do this they'd go to cheerleading
competitions
but but a cheerleading competition
doesn't make any sense
because the purpose of cheerleading is
to cheer on the team if you take the
team out of it and you've just got the
cheerleaders cheerleading becomes
something entirely different now some
people say well cheerleading is very
difficult yeah it can certainly can be
cheerleading is kind of like gymnastics
yeah it is if you want to do that join
the gymnastics team but it doesn't it
doesn't make any sense to make
cheerleading just about itself
cheerleading is intrinsically something
about other people we don't make sense
of that anymore we don't understand
anymore that something can be beyond
ourselves that the point of something
can be beyond our own desires and and
pleasure that actually there we have to
think of other people
and other people's views and society and
the objective reality and all it goes it
goes
all the way from the craziest example
which is these dudes who are pretending
to be chicks all the way down to the
totally ordinary facets of life which
used to be about the common good which
used to be about serving your family and
your community and your god and now in
virtually every aspect of life have been
turned on ourselves and a man
wrapped up in himself makes a very small
package indeed especially when he's
wearing a cheerleading uniform did you
like that clip i'm glad you did ring
ding like slam smash you know whatever
whatever you got to do
subscribe get the notifications to the
michael knowles show also head on over
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe over there go to
dailywire.com subscribe or just
subscribe everywhere and leave a five
star review wherever you can we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you